cuando queremos saber la fecha de un día
especial casi siempre la buscamos en el
calendario por ejemplo yo quiero saber
qué día festejaremos el cumpleaños de mi
mamá ella cumpleaños el 11 de mayo así
que veamos el calendario oops tengo un
problema creo que algo le falta mi
calendario está un poco vacío me ayudas
a completarlo con los días que le faltan
así podré saber qué día festejaremos el
cumpleaños de mi mamá
en nuestro calendario tenemos ya el
número 1 después del 1 escribimos el 2
luego aparece el 3 4 5 del 5 sigue el 6
y luego el 7 vamos muy bien tenemos ya
el 8 y el 9 ya casi llegamos al
cumpleaños de mi mamá después del 9
tenemos que escribir el 10 y el 11 listo
hemos llegado al cumpleaños de mi mamá
el 11 de mayo esto quiere decir que será
un jueves pero ya que estamos en esto
tenemos que completar el calendario
falta muy poco después del 11 está el 12
falta el 13 el 14 ya aparece luego
escribimos el 15 tenemos el 16 y el 17
pero nos faltan varios números el 18 19
20 y 21 como tenemos el 22
entonces escribimos el 23 y el 24 está
el 25
falta el 26 el 27 y el 28 llegamos al 29
y muy bien solo nos falta el 30
hemos completado nuestro calendario
leamos rápido la serie 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
23 24 25 26 27 28 29 31 31 excelente
esto lo hice con una fecha especial como
el cumpleaños de mi mamá pero tú puedes
practicar con las fechas que quieras
ahora imagina que irás con tu mejor
amigo al cine tus boletos dicen que
tienen asignados los asientos 22 y 23
pero cuando entran a la sala y no están
numerados los únicos asientos que se
alcanzan a ver numerados son el 1 el 12
y el 15 entonces cómo sabemos que
asientos te tocan es muy fácil vamos
contando los asientos hasta encontrar
los tuyos empecemos desde el 1 luego el
4 5 y 6 bien en la primera fila tenemos
haciendo del 1 al 6 el a 112 es el de la
orilla a la derecha eso quiere decir que
empezamos del lado izquierdo con el
asiento 7 luego el 8 9 10 11 y llegamos
al 12 de este lado sigue el 13 14 ya
tenemos el 15 por lo que continuamos con
el 16 17 y 18 entonces la tercera fila
es del 13 al 18 sigamos contando ya casi
llegamos a los asientos que te tocan
para disfrutar tu película ponemos el 19
aquí luego el 20 21 y entonces los
siguientes dos asientos son los tuyos 22
y 23 muy bien sigamos contando para
enumerar todos los asientos de la sala
ya sólo nos falta el 24 por acá el 25 26
27 28 29 y 30 super como ya te diste
cuenta es muy útil saber y escribir los
números estos solo fueron dos
situaciones en las que
que contar pero seguro tendrás que
utilizarlos muchas ocasiones más